When building an app that uses
the Google services, you'll generally
use an Asynchronous Programing Model
that looks a little bit like this.
In the onCreate of your activity,
you create a Google API client.
And then in the onStart
of your activity,
you connect that Google API
client to the relevant APIs.
In this case Location Services.
In order to use this,
you're going to need to override
a number of different methods.
One is OnConnectionFailed,
which the services will
call whenever the connection drops and
you need to handle what to do.
Generally just reconnecting.
One is OnConnectionSuspended, which is
very similar to OnConnectionFailed and
will be called if the connection gets
suspended but not necessarily broken.
And you might want to
cache some information.
When you succeed in making
a connection to Location Services,
Location services calls
back to OnConnected,
telling you that you're now
connected to the services.
And in the case of
something like location,
you'll then create a LocationRequest.
They had passed to Location Services
to get your location details back.
And it would call you back
with OnLocationChanged,
letting you know that your location
request details have changed,
and there's new location
information available to you.
And you'll get a Location object,
which you can then use
to write to your screen.
So in the application that we just saw,
that location object included
a latitude, and I was able to update
my screen and write the latitude to it.
Now this programming model isn't
just limited to location services.
As I've said, many of the services that
you'll be using during this course
follow a very similar
programming model to this.
You're going to have an OnCreate and
an OnStart.
You're going to have a GoogleApiClient
that you connect to the services that
you want to use.
And then you have to
handle certain overrides.
Usually, they'll be OnConnectionFailed,
OnConnectionSuspended, OnConnected, and
then an override that's specific
to the services that you're using.
In this case, it's OnLocationChanged for
location services.